there is another Congressional sex tape
involving a couple of fellas this one
apparently circulated on Snapchat last
year but for those of us who are are not
in those circles we're only finding out
about it now conveniently after this
other sex tape this is from the story of
a user going by Adam J uh recordings of
this were viewed by semaphor and
mercifully not by all of us uh but
semaphor says that the videos featured a
man inside a house office buil
doing something alone this is a family
show I'm going to try to clean it up you
know uh he was doing what Woody Allen
referred to as sleeping with someone you
love uh and then there was also another
one with a dude with two two men uh
engaged in something unfortunate uh the
participants faces are not visible in
any of this material